Dr. John Dolittle lived in a small town called Puddleby.
He lived in a small house, but he had a large garden.
He kept many animals in his garden.
Dr. Dolittle did not have many patients.
Most people did not like all his animals.
One day, the cat's meatman said to him,...
..."Why don't you stop being a doctor for people and become a doctor for animals instead?"
"You know a lot about animals, more than most vets, I'm sure."
When the cat's meatman left, Polynesia, the parrot, flew onto the table.
"He's right, Doctor," Polynesia said. "You should become an animal doctor."
"There are a lot of vets," Dr. Dolittle said.
"Perhaps there are, but you'd be the best vet of all."
"I'm not the only animal that can talk."
"All the animals can talk. Each kind of animal has its own language."
"I'll teach you mine if you like."
Every day, Dr. Dolittle learned the languages of the animals.
When people found out he was now an animal doctor, they brought their pets to him.
Before long, every animal that lived in or near Puddleby became the doctor's patients.
He was very happy and he liked his life very much.